[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le journal de tv 78 pour
un condensé d'actualité locale bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez dans cette
édition du jeudi 7 novembre voici les
titres
il toucherait 7% des élèves selon
l'éducation nationale le harcèlement
scolaire
un fléau dont c'est la journée nationale
de lutte aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
des associations se mobilisent comme de
l'enfance à l'adolescence sa présidente
est notre invité polémique autour du
bois l'attentât contre la mosquée de
bayonne les musulmans de france ont été
particulièrement visé ces dernières
semaines dimanche une marche contre
l'islamophobie est organisée à paris
nous verrons comment les musulmans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vivre cette
période
et puis sa campagne est officiellement
lancé le maire sentant de guyancourt
françois morton sera candidat aux
élections municipales il a été élu en
mai dernier est dans une ville qui a
connu trois édiles depuis 2014
et puis vous en avez l'habitude chaque
jeudi dans ce journal la sélection des
idées de sorties à faire ce week-end
dans les environs et c'est en plus un
week-end prolongé le 7 novembre c'est la
journée nationale contre le harcèlement
scolaire un temps pour faire le point
sur la prise en compte de ce fléau 7%
des élèves en france serait touchée
selon les derniers chiffres de
l'éducation nationale pour parler de ce
sujet pascal go très bon soir dans ça
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
de l'enfance à l'adolescence dont l'une
des missions justement c'est de prévenir
toutes les formes de harcèlement vous
intervenez dans les écoles des vies on
aura l'occasion d'en parler juste après
déjà vous faire réagir sur ce chiffre 7
% d'élèves concernés ça paraît
finalement ps que le le principal
problème c'est que les jeunes n'osent
pas parler encore aujourd'hui oui vous
avez raison effectivement un enfant qui
est harcelé ne va pas forcément oser le
dire en parler à l'adulte pourquoi parce
qu'il peut être l'objet d'un chantage on
peut lui dire beaucoup te situes tu vas
dénoncer et bien je vais agir sur ton
ami ou sur 2 tab 6 heures l'enfant qui
ne veut pas inquiéter ses parents donc
il va taire ce harcèlement sur 2 7% et
peut-être frontier mais bien sûr on peut
imaginer que ce n'est que l'iceberg en
fait que la partie est la partie visible
de l'iceberg d'un malade qui est
beaucoup plus important puisqu'on sait
que chez les adolescents aujourd'hui le
mal-être est vraiment très important
qu'est-ce que depuis la création de
votre association en 2008 c'est un
phénomène qui a gagné en ampleur est ce
que c'est une constatation que vous
faites
nous on a pu le constater effectivement
on a de plus en plus d'enfants qui sont
dans le mal être et effectivement le
harcèlement est l'une des causes de ce
mal être quand je parle de ma lettre il
faut savoir qu'une fille sur cinq
aujourd'hui à 15 ans a fait une
tentative de suicide donc c'est vraiment
des chiffres qui font froid dans le dos
et est-ce qu'on peut l'expliquer aux 6,7
cette augmentation du phénomène par la
recrudescence aujourd'hui des écrans la
place prépondérante qu'on les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui non le harcèlement
ça s'arrête pas juste à l'école comme
avant ça peut continuer à domicile aussi
vous avez raison autrefois le
harcèlement c'était le harcèlement
scolaire c'était dans la cour dans
l'enceinte de
de l'établissement scolaire aujourd'hui
avec les réseaux sociaux c'est en fait
un harcèlement non-stop puisque on le
sait internet ne dort jamais et bien le
harcèlement ne s'arrête jamais et
l'enfant doit vraiment endurer cette
maltraitance de 7 par ses pairs et voilà
c'est pour ça que c'est très dur pour
lui et que les conséquences sont fortes
aussi les conséquences de certaines
parlent pas justement ce jeune comment
on peut déceler les signaux qui voilà
qui pourrait laisser à penser qu'il ya
un harcèlement
d'ailleurs il faut imaginer que ça peut
arriver au mans l'adolescence et
attention non la donner il ne fait pas
sa crise
il est fort possible qu effectivement
une maille fabien et comment est-ce
qu'on va le déceler et bien les
résultats vont vont chuter
il peut y avoir aussi un changement dans
son comportement
c'était un enfant qui était très enjoué
d'un seul coup il va se renfermer
c'était un enfant qui pouvait sourire
aujourd'hui va pas du tout avoir de
l'humour
les fleurs d'appétit aussi aussi tout à
fait manque de sommeil aussi il peut ne
plus pouvoir dormir
effectivement alors pour lutter contre
ce fléau le ministère de l'éducation
nationale forment les jeunes 1500
ambassadeur contre le harcèlement dans
les collèges et lycées de l'académie de
versailles
elle va expérimenter aussi l'académie la
formation des parents écoutez à ce
propos la rectrice de l'académie invité
ce matin de nos confrères de france bleu
paris c'est une nouveauté que je vais
expérimenter cette année j'espère
qu'elle portera ses fruits
en effet c'est un sujet collectif et
donc on va former 25 par an pour
commencer j'espère beaucoup plus très
vite les formés à détecter des signaux
faibles les signaux forts les former a
invité les enfants à parler et puis les
former aussi à réagir à faire confiance
à l'institution
pascal co 13 que former les parents
c'est une bonne idée ce que finances
sont eux aussi qui peuvent détecter ces
signaux c'est une excellente idée parce
qu'en fait il faut former il faut
outiller toute personne qui gravitent
autour de l'enfant alors que ce soit eh
bien les enseignants les personnes qui
sont dans l'enceinte scolaire est
évidemment les parents puisque c'est eux
qui font détectés par exemple le manque
de sommeil ou même
le manque d'appétit parce que finalement
celles qui connaissent le mieux l'enfant
est effectivement voir son enfant
s'éteindre c'est bien les parents qui
vont pouvoir le voir mais si on parle de
l'engagement de votre association
justement contre ce fléau de du
harcèlement il y à des actions
préventives c'est à dire avant qu'il y
ait harcèlement mais aussi en curatif
une fois qu'il ya eu harcèlement c'est
ça alors oui nous on intervient en fait
en curatif et en préventif alors en
curatif se sont en organise des groupes
de parole pour développer en fait le
bien-être de l'enfant on va faire des
petits effectifs
on va faire en sorte que les garçons et
des filles soient séparés pour qu'en
fait les plus réservés puisse prendre la
parole et puis on va leur dire quelque
chose dès le départ quelque chose qu'ils
n'entendent pas assez souvent vous êtes
tous intelligents et alors tout le monde
sera remis à niveau même celui qui est
abaissée normalement dans la vie
scolaire
lorsqu'il ya un gros travail dans votre
association en tout cas sur l'estimé de
soi pourquoi ça peut être intéressant
estime de soi justement pour lutter
contre le harcèlement
le point de départ chez nous c'est
vraiment les styles de soi un enfant qui
est harcelé et qui a une bonne estime de
lui même
et bien finalement le harcèlement va
glisser sur lui il va avoir de la
répartie et si jamais il a été harcelé
il aura une bonne résilience un enfant
qui a une bonne estime de soi il a
aucune raison d'harceler parce que il
est bien il a pas besoin d'amoindrir
quelqu'un pour être quelqu'un donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui pour nous est
primordial de travailler sur l'estimé de
soi est ce que dans ces groupes de
paroles que vous animez ce que la parole
se libère plus facilement du coup quand
vous les organiser ah oui on n'a jamais
eu en fait de timidité vraiment chacun
prend sa place je pense que on
intervient aussi en binôme on a
l'habitude de le faire
et puis les enfants ont besoin de parler
vous êtes intervenu à ce jour près de
2000 enfants dans les yvelines cessa de
1000 jeunes que ce soit au collège et au
lycée aux primaires aussi aux primaires
primaires aussi et
le dernier en date donc on était
intervenue dans un collège à houdan et
là on voit que les résultats sont
extraordinaires puisque non seulement
l'équipe des surveillants l'a senti les
enseignants aussi et puis il ya quelque
chose qui est statistiquement vraiment
vérifiable c'est grâce à pronote qui est
le logiciel qui va gérer et qui gère la
vie dans l'enceinte scolaire et on voit
qu'il ya eu les incidents ont
complètement baissé
donc c'est vraiment une résulte un
résultat extraordinaire pour nous donc
c'est très encourageant nos actions ça
s'appelle l'action smile et c'est vrai
qu'on aimerait que tous nos enfants va
se redresse et puisse avoir le sourire
on retrouve toutes les actualités toutes
les informations de votre association
sur son site internet merci parce
qu'elle voterait d'être venu en plateau
merci de nous avoir interrogé sur ce
sujet qui est important et je rappelle
que vous êtes la présidente de
l'association de l'enfance à
l'adolescence j'ajoute aussi qu'un
numéro d'appel pour les victimes ou
témoins de harcèlement existe un numéro
d'appel des coûts' et le 30 20 services
et appels gratuits un mot de politique
c'était dans les cartons mais la
décision a été officialisée ce matin
françois morton mer depuis mai dernier à
guyancourt a annoncé son intention de se
représenter lors des élections
municipales les détails avec ce sujet de
michael et me d'euros c'est autour d'un
petit déjeuner que françois morton lance
officiellement sa campagne à guyancourt
conseiller municipal depuis 2014 est
maire depuis mai 2010 neuf l'homme
politique veut se présenter aux
élections municipales de mars prochain
pour rencontrer très régulièrement et au
quotidien l'ensemble des années des
habitants guyancourt je sais qu'ils
apprécient effectivement les actions et
les réalisations mises en place durant
ce dernier mandat c'était déjà le cas
dans les mandats précédents mais il
s'avère que je n'étais pas élu à
l'époque donc je mais j'assume
totalement ce bilan et on en est
particulièrement fier françois morton à
50 ans sera le chef de file de
guyancourt pour tous une liste divers
gauche reconduite pour la troisième fois
moi je suis un homme de beau jeu les
toujours été il s'avère que je n'adhère
à aucun parti politique si ça avait été
le cas je n'aurais eu aucune raison de
m'en cacher mais ça n'est pas le cas par
contre je suis un homme de gauche et
donc l'étiquette logique est celle de
divers gauche pendant ce mandat la liste
qu en cours pour tous a subi quelques
secousses ont 6 ans trois maires se sont
succédé à la tête de la commune avant
françois morton françois de ligne en
2016 et marie
est-il le tarnec en avril 2019 ont
quitté leur poste de maire c'est un peu
inédit 1,3 mer durant un mandat bon ça
n'arrive pas à chaque fois donc voilà
c'est comme ça ce sont les aléas de la
vie
pour moi ce n'est pas un sujet et ça
n'est pas un sujet pour les habitants de
la ville la liste définitive avec 50% de
renouvellement sera connu d'ici fin
janvier début février 2020 françois
morton devrait être opposé à rodolphe
baril de la liste ensemble agissons pour
lui en cours à grégory pape de nouvel
élan guyancourt et olivier paréja de
décider ensemble pour guyancourt olivier
parent et jacky a été a désigné cette
semaine tête de liste de décidons
ensemble à guyancourt une candidature
participative dont le processus remonte
à fin 2010 8 publication d'un manifeste
collecte d'idées auprès des habitants
avant d'établir un programme basé sur
dix axes forts olivier paris jacky est
conseiller municipal de guyancourt et
siège toujours aujourd'hui au sein de la
majorité les dire stop à l'islamophobie
c'est le but de ce rassemblement prévu
dimanche à paris la marche partira de la
gare du nord et se rendra jusqu'à nation
une initiative soutenue par plus de
cinquante personnalités dans une tribune
parue dans le journal libération cette
semaine et c'est pour répondre à ce
climat actuel qui vise les musulmans de
france une polémique autour du voile
l'attentât à la mosquée de bayonne fin
octobre comment est vécue cette période
par les musulmans des yvelines on va
poser la question à nos deux invités
joker bouchlaghem bonsoir comment ça
vous êtes habitante de guyancourt vous
nous direz tout à l'heure pour quoi vous
vous portez le voile et comment vous
vivez cette polémique est mort à dali
bonsoir bonsoir président de la leaf à
elancourt vous êtes également le
président du cam 78 c'est le collectif
des associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
environs ce déferlement comment est il
vécu par les musulmans de confession
musulmane les musulmans les saint
quentinois pardon de confession
musulmane à saint quentin en yvelines
alors merci pour votre invitation et
merci pour la formulation de votre
question car vous parlez de déferlement
il s'agit bien de cela donc
on voit depuis un certain temps
maintenant que c'est un enchaînement de
prise de parole dans les médias par
certains politiques à l'endroit de
l'islam et des musulmans et on pourrait
croire que c'est la préoccupation
première des français
or des sondages montrent qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres préoccupations
notamment l'année dernière on a vécu une
année particulièrement dur sur le haut
niveau social avec des manifestations
des protestations et toutes ces
préoccupations ont été relégués est
aujourd'hui un focus effet sur l'islam
et les musulmans
le problème est que le focus donne lieu
et donne place ensuite à des actes et à
des propos islamophobes
vous parlez de musulmans yvelinois et je
vous remercie de ne pas parler de
communauté musulmane parce qu on
reproche souvent aux musulmans d'être
communautariste mais on utilise ce terme
de communauté musulmane comme si c'était
un groupe dans le groupe national non
les musulmans sont des français de
confession musulmane
est ce qu'il ya une inquiétude
aujourd'hui ah oui elle est réelle et
légitime c'est inquiétude est basé par
cette exacerbation des propos notamment
sur certaines chaînes d'information par
la présence de certains polémiste ayant
été jugée le condamner à qui on donne
des tribunes et aujourd'hui il ya encore
quelques mois une cellule terroriste a
été démantelé
donc qui prévoyait des attentats contre
les musulmans des musulmanes ont été
attaqués sur la voie publique
et puis plus récemment encore on n'a
plus vu on a pu voir cette sortie
médiatique et d'un élu extrémistes qui
étaient totalement illégales parce qu'il
semblerait qu'ils ne connaissent pas ce
qu'est la laïcité lors du conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
instant en octobre en élus du
rassemblement national a demandé en se
référant à tort ou texte de loi une
femme dans le public de retirer son
voile justement
sur sur le voile il ya eu aussi les mots
du ministre de l'éducation nationale 1
qui a dit que le voile n'est pas
souhaitable dans notre société ce que
vous comprenez vous cette polémique
qu'il ya actuellement autour du voile
alors non en tant que française
j'entends je peux comprendre que l'on
puisse s'intéresser au vol après quand
j'entends quand j'entends parler de
débat mois pour moi c'est par les
dialogues c'est la communication
là on assiste beaucoup plus à
l'acharnement médiatique politique
donc non pour moi je sais ça je ne le
comprends pas c'est pas une une raison
de vouloir s'acharner comme ça sur les
femmes qui portent le foulard
je préfèrerais le terme foulard de
couleur pourquoi là justement pourquoi
je vous avais fait tous les scores de
couleur à bas tout simplement c'est un
cheminement personnel que j'ai fait il
ya maintenant huit ans c'est que c'est
un choix c'est une réflexion c'est une
introspection sur moi même ça a été le
parcours de beaucoup de lectures de
méditation c'est très philosophique
c'est vraiment un choix personnel et
c'est quand je mets mon voile c'est
vraiment voilà je me sens entière et je
me sens bien mais qu'est ce que vous
considérez des femmes musulmanes qui ne
portent pas justement le foulard alors
excusez moi je trouve vraiment un peu
cette question légèrement aux déplacés
j'entends par là que ce sont des choix
que l'on fait ce sont des choix
personnels
chaque femme a le droit de choisir sa
manière la manière dont elle s'habille
dont ses actes ce qu'elle dit ce qu'elle
fait comme tout être être sensé d'une
raison et j'estime que voilà je n'ai
absolument pas d'avis à donner l'écho
elle reste des femmes musulmanes j'ai
bien bossé je suis bien passer par la
case de ne pas l'avoir porté avant de le
porter et je ne me sens pas je ne me
sentais pas moins croyantes et
pratiquantes
voilà ce sont tout à fait respectable
comme moi je suis respectable et que tu
as également mais est-ce que depuis vous
porter le foulard vous avez eu des
soucis dans votre vie de tous les jours
au travail notamment est ce que tu lui
des soucis rencontrés alors oui le
travail faut taire la vérité en tant que
femme portant le foulard c'est on a
beaucoup de barrières des portes qui se
ferment que ce soit dans le travail
après on nous le dit pas directement
c'est toujours de manière indirecte mais
que soit le travail que ce soit les
activités là pour le coup scolaire ou
après moi personnellement ça va pour
l'instant au niveau scolaire y avait pas
eu de soucis mais voilà les activités le
sport la piscine ensuite dans la rue
dans beaucoup d'autres plus de regards
appuyés
voilà des gens qui me regardent de
manière un peu à ceux qui se posent des
questions mais ça a toujours existé où
ça s'est accéléré dernièrement alors on
danse a toujours existé par contre bien
sûr avec tous ces débats là que l'on
entend à la télé sur internet à longueur
de journée c'est sûr que ça s'accélère
et ça c'est ce qu'on va le ressentir
beaucoup plus surtout nous les femmes
qui sommes plus facilement pointé du
doigt et plus facilement à victimiser
alors pour endiguer cette polémique une
marche contre l'islamophobie se déroule
ce dimanche à paris une cinquantaine de
personnalités a appuyé à rejoindre
l'initiative
murad ali que pensez-vous de cette
initiative est aussi du soutien
il ya des personnalités de toutes
confessions voilà de toutes croyances
qui ont signé cet appel écoutez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en france
la démarche d'une protestation ou d'une
manifestation face à face à ce que l'on
considère comme une injustice
c'est profondément ancré dans l'adn des
français depuis très longtemps et
aujourd'hui face à une injustice chacun
doit pouvoir s'exprimer aussi bien la
victime que les personnes qui
considèrent tout en étant extérieur à
cette situation d'injustice que ce n'est
pas acceptable et que ce soit cela doit
cesser
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui ne sont pas de confession musulmane
qui se sont associés à cette démarche là
et c'est tout à fait normal puisque il
regrette ce climat nauséabond et
hystérique à l'endroit de l'islam et des
musulmans
et il le condamne de quelle manière le
condamner ya plusieurs manières ça peut
être en s'exprimant à l'oral en
s'exprimant sur un plateau télé en
faisant une pétition ou en faisant une
marche une manifestation ça reste des
choses autorisée par la loi et
aujourd'hui par contre on observe un
espèce de diktat de la pensée ou voir de
l'action puisque ça fait déjà une
polémique il ya certaines personnes qui
ne seraient pas à l'aise de d'y
participer en raison de la présence
d'autres personnes ou alors parce que
c'est l'islamophobie
il faudrait peut-être définir les choses
l'islamophobie n'est pas le droit de
critiquer l'islam
l'islamophobie c'est c'est donc une
discrimination à l'endroit d'une
personne ou d'une institution en raison
de sa de son appartement son
appartenance pardon réelle ou supposée à
l'islam
donc c'est une discrimination donc de la
même manière qu'en qualifier un racisme
à l'endroit des personnes de confession
juive
on l'appelle antisémitisme aujourd'hui
le racisme à l'endroit des personnes de
confession musulmane ou identifié comme
étant de confirmation du jugement
les personnes ou les institutions
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle i stem
islamophobie je pense qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de pinailler de débattre sur le
terme et sur l'étymologie parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres termes sur lesquelles
on pourrait débattre aujourd'hui ce
terme-là est actée par certaines
organisations telles que l'onu où la
ligue des droits de l'homme et
aujourd'hui un article de droit un
article du code pénal très rapidement ce
qu'on démolit déjà l'entretien qui qui
qui condamne donc ses propos ses actes
merci mourad d'allier je rappelle vous
êtes le président du cam 78 et merci
pour votre témoignage de m bush la gamme
merci à vous de dire si cette action
solidaire à présent à voisins le
bretonneux hier mercredi sur le parvis
de la mairie les enfants de la
commission humanitaire du conseil
municipal des jeunes ont remis plusieurs
cartons à éducation et développement des
vêtements des jeux des livres et du
matériel informatique collectées pendant
plusieurs semaines au profit de cette
association al oeuvre auprès des enfants
du bénin pour l'accès à la connaissance
et au numérique son président et
fondateur et vice ynwa les propos sont
accueillis par manon varaldo aujourd'hui
pour charger des camions avec des des
cartons qui vont aller au bénin pour
l'association éducation et développement
de monsieur james qatar et le président
de l'association monsieur qatari il
essaye de donner accès aux enfants à
tous les outils informatiques et il crée
des salles avec à disposition une
quinzaine d'ordinateurs et les jeunes
viennent de partout notre équivalent par
exemple du 77 jusque dans le 78 pour
avoir accès à ces ordinateurs et il
travaille aussi avec des orphelinats
d'où le besoin de vêtements de livres de
jeux éducatifs
avec cette ouverture une quarantaine
d'emplois été créée abercrombie and
fitch vient d'implanter son deuxième
magasin en france qu enseigne américaine
de mode s'est installée au sein du
centre commercial parly 2 au chesnay rck
en cours le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros c'est une première dans un
centre commercial français la marque
abercrombie and fitch créé en 1892 aux
états unis a ouvert le 18 octobre
dernier à westfield de parly 2 le second
magasin de l'enseigné en france après
les champs-elysées pourquoi ans entre
tout simplement pour être plus proche du
client
on souhaite se développer en france et
partout en france donc effectivement les
choisi c'était intéressant beaucoup
tourisme pour nos locaux sera les
centres commerciaux première marque
roumaine fitch dans un centre a parlé
et bien d'autres encore on l'espère au
total le magasin dispose de 300 m² pour
exposer ses collections homme et femme
les cabines insolites ont également été
installés tous trouveront ici et je vous
fais le test la lumière qu'on peut
augmenter ou pas vous avez différents
types de lumière standard d'ailleurs sa
pole
excusez moi pour l'accent anglais et la
musique country ou quoi que ce soit
c'est leur dette d'un conseil où fait
guy vasseur ring et on en as aussi qui
est automatiquement le message et
viendra en cave et nous aider avec
l'arrivée de l'enseignent le centre aux
11,3 millions de visiteurs en 2018
espère montrer les muscles et encore
booster sa fréquentation
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à la roue mais
c'est une marque internationale
extrêmement connue outre-atlantique
d'abord puis en france sur les
champs-elysées
c'est quand même extraordinaire de faire
venir voilà le deuxième magasin ici dans
l'ouest parisien
avec cette ouverture une quarantaine
d'emplois ont été créés le magasin
pourrait recruter les effectifs
supplémentaires pour la période de noël
le gault et millau 2020 a été dévoilée
plus de 3200 adresses y sont recensés
parmi elles deux ans trivino à celle de
jean-baptiste lavergne morandini de la
table ronde à versailles
classé parmi les six grands de demain il
a été formé notamment au trianon à
versailles a ouvert son propre
restaurant en 2015 la table du onze ce
prodige de la cuisine a reçu sa première
étoile
onze mois après son installation à
seulement 27 ans autre entrée celle de
xavier pincemin qui figurent dans les
trente et un jeunes talents lui aussi a
été formé au trianon palace à versailles
et vainqueur de la saison 7 de top chef
il a ouvert son restaurant cet été le
pincemin dans la cité royale
tous deux ont été reçus dernièrement
dans l'émission vais y t regardez j'ai
grandi dans un restaurant mais
ma grand-mère remonter les assurant la
maison des bois ou la santa pauline
entre plaisir et pontchartrain est une
vieille auberge avec des jolis produits
donc j'ai toujours vu sa commande à
caser les seuls venir tout ça donc j'ai
des souvenirs quand même j'ai un rapport
à la mickey j'ai jamais voulu ouvrir mon
restaurant parce que j'ai toujours voulu
être chef dans un palace c'était mon
rêve de d'enfants dans l'ain du casse
tout ça c'était waouh c'est incroyable
finalement il y a il ya quoi ya deux ans
je me suis dit mais en fait si j'ai un
patron toujours je pourrais jamais faire
ce que je veux dans ma cuisine
ce qu'il faut savoir que les directeurs
ils ont leur mot à dire et on sollicite
alors j'ai voulu faire ma cuisine je
vais essayé d'ouvrir mon restaurant et
au final bas j'ai cherché j'ai voulu la
liberté de la créativité
[Musique]
c'est un nouveau week-end de trois jours
qui vous attendent quoi profiter de
diverses animations proposées à saint
quentin en yvelines pour en parler
mélanie poké bonsoir vous avez identifié
deux animations pour nous un peu de
sport et beaucoup de jeu le club mouche
de plaisir organise une initiation d'une
discipline peu connue la pêche à la
mouche une initiation 100% réservé aux
femmes c'est une idée de la présidente
qui croise peu de pratiquants de
féminines alors dès 8h30 samedi 9
novembre vous apprendrez tous les
secrets pour pêcher à la mouche et vous
pourrez vous testez l'après-midi sur le
plan d'eau du château de la ville
la pêche à la mouche consiste à attraper
le poisson mais de le relâcher tout de
suite et en plus on pêche avec des
hameçons parce que i'm so i lya pour
attraper du poisson qui ne font pas mal
parce qu'il n'ya plus d'art dit ion n'ya
pas le petit crochet qui est à
l'intérieur du de l'hameçon pour cela il
n'y a pas d' appât naturel donc on ne
met pas les mains dans le pot 2 sticks
au ni ni à les sortir des vers des vers
de terre
donc on est sur une pêche qui est propre
alors pour les intéressés une
inscription et demandes et les
informations s'affichent en bas de
l'écran
pour participer il faut être âgé d'au
moins 12 ans
le lendemain le 10 novembre
l'élu dit dave qui débute à saint
quentin en yvelines et oui ça débute
même à la commanderie où il va y avoir
des intrigues à résoudre alors pour
démarrer c'est lui 10 days il y a trois
rendez vous qui vous attendent
deux thèmes des skins game y aura aussi
de murder party mais aussi un espace
jeux libres ces animations sont sur
réservation et on accédait par nasser
l'espace jeux qui est juste pour
profiter du plaisir de jouer en famille
ou entre amis et un dimanche qui lance
un deux semaines autour du jeu l'élu 10
days se déroule dans les médiathèques de
saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 23
novembre merci mélanie pour ce point
d'information ses idées de sorties et on
en aura d'autres dans quelques instants
le cqp loisirs qui est présenté par vous
et c'est juste après ce journal voilà la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
est demain vendredi place aux 7,8
l'hebdo retour sur l'actualité de la
semaine dans les yvelines
et c'est avec marylène iapichino belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]